WE'LL MOVE OUT--OH!
- [yells]
- WHAT WAS THAT?
- OH, MY GOD.
THAT IS A MOUSE
WITH A RAT FACE AND A RAT TAIL.
- OH!
- OOH.
- IT'S LIKE FIEVEL GOES--
OH, MY GOD!
[all shouting]
- DUDE, GO, GO!
- OOH.
- OKAY.
- WHOO!
- OH, MY GOD.
YOU GUYS, WE'RE NOT GONNA GET
OUR SECURITY DEPOSIT BACK
WITH THOSE THINGS RUNNING AROUND
IN THERE.
[all yelling]
[heavy metal music]
- FALCON PUNCH!
[rat squeaks]
- [yelling]
[rat squeaking]
- [yells]
- [grunting]
[rat squeaking]
[all grunting]
- OH!
- OH, YEAH!
all: DIP FORWARD AND BACK
AND KICK AND--
- YEAH.
- [grunts]
- AAH!
[rat squeaking]
- [grunts]
- WHOO!
[all grunting]
♪
- WE ARE THE RAT BUSTERS!
- [sighs]
- THAT WAS AWESOME.
I WAS LIKE, AAH!
THE ONE--
THE ONE EYE POPPED OUT,
AND I SAW YOU,
YOU WERE LIKE, "KABOOSH!"
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
- JUST KABOOSHED IT SO HARD.
- THANK YOU.
- DERS, YOU GOT A SQUADOOSH.
I SAW THAT.
- YEAH, I DID.
- THAT WAS AWESOME--I LOVE
BEING MANIACS WITH YOU GUYS.
- PRETTY GOOD LAST ADVENTURE.
- [clicks tongue]
LAST ONE.
- YEAH.
- YEP.
- FRICKIN' HATE YOU DUDES.
[laughter]
YOU GUYS SUCK.
OH, [bleep] YOU.
- YOU'RE A BITCH.
- YEAH, YOU'RE A BITCH.
- YOU'RE A BITCH TOO.
- IF I SAW YOU IN THE STREETS,
I'D BE LIKE,
"LET'S GUN THIS DUDE DOWN.
I HATE HIM."
- SHUT UP.
- I HATE YOU.
- SHUT UP, BITCH.
- YOU SHUT UP.
[rat squeaks]
ANOTHER RAT!
FINAL ADVENTURE EXTENDED!
- OKAY!
- HERE WE GO!
- WHOO!
[rats squeaking]
[all screaming]
- OH, OKAY.
- EW! EW!
- YEP.
NO, THAT IS A--THAT'S A NEST.
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL
A RAT NEST, AND IT IS HUGE.
- THEY'RE ALL JUST IN THERE
JUST [bleep],
JUST HUMPING ON TOP
OF EACH OTHER.
- WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
- WELL, LET'S JUST,
UH, GO GET SHMACKED, RIGHT,
AND ASSUME THAT SOMEONE ELSE
WILL TAKE CARE OF THIS.
- NO!
HEY, LOOK.
- YEP.
- THIS IS OUR PROBLEM.
WE'RE GONNA STEP UP,
AND IT'S GONNA HAPPEN BY BLAKE
COMING UP WITH ONE OF
YOUR CREATIVE, CRAZY IDEAS
TO GET THOSE RATS OUT OF HERE
AND INTO SOME KIND OF BOX
OR CONTAINER.
- I DON'T KNOW, GUYS.
I JUST--
- COME ON.
- OH, I AM A FREAKIN'
FULL-GROWN BABY GENIUS.
I GOT IT, YEAH.
A PIZZA SUIT.
PUT A BUNCH OF PIZZA ON THIS--
ON A SUIT,
AND THEN THE RATS ALL COME TO IT
AND THEY--AND THEY GE--
THEY START EATIN' IT...
- OH, THAT'S GOOD.
- AND THEN WHILE THEY'RE EATIN'
IT YOU STRIP IT OFF
AND YOU--YOU PUT IT ON THE--
THE SLINGSHOT FROM THE AMERICAN
GLADIATE-DERS, RIGHT?
- OH, THAT'S GOOD!
- YES! DERS, YEAH.
- AND THEN WE LAUNCH IT
INTO SPACE!
- YEAH, OR AT LEAST
THE NEIGHBOR'S YARD.
- YEAH, EXACTLY, YOU KNOW?
- YEAH, YEAH.
- NOW I GUESS ALL WE GOT TO FIND
IS SOMEBODY LOCO ENOUGH TO GET
IN THAT SUIT, RIGHT?
- EXACTLY.
- MY COUSIN DANNY'S LOCO.
AT FAMILY BARBEQUES, HE'LL TAKE
HIS PENIS OUT AND PUT IT
IN A HOTDOG BUN
AND WILL WALK AROUND TO MY AUNT
AND BE LIKE...
[English accent]
"ARE YOU HUNGRY
FOR SOME SAUSAGES?"
AND THEN--HE'S NOT EVEN BRITISH.
- OKAY, YEAH.
THAT'S LOCO.
I-I WAS REFERRING TO YOU THOUGH.
- YOU GUYS THINK I'M LOCO?
- YEAH.
[English accent]
- WELL, I WOULD BE HONORED.
- ALL RIGHT.
- DON'T DO THE ACCENT,
THOUGH.
- OKAY, WELL, THEN I WOULD BE--
I WOULD BE HONORED.
- COOL.
- YEAH, OKAY.
[grunts]
[rats squeaking]
[yells]
[rats squealing]
[screams]
- WHOA!
- OH! OH!
- WHOA! WHOA! WHOA!
- THEY'RE BITING THROUGH
MY SUIT!
I CAN FEEL THEIR TEETH!
OH, GOD! OH, MAN!
- I CAN'T--
I CAN'T GET TO
THE ZIPPER, MAN, JUST--